[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance any essential distinction
between Donald Trump being merely an
idiot marionette belonging to Vladimir
Putin and Donald Trump behaving like an
active Russian agent has been fully
erased in the course of just over one
week and it has been erased by Donald
Trump when the damning stain of
illegitimate grows on this presidency
week by week hour by hour when every
moment of the political discourse of
this nation becomes consumed by a debate
over not whether he has been placed in
office by the efforts of a foreign power
but a debate over how much of that
subversion he knew in advance he will
have no one to blame but himself because
he cannot leave it alone because every
move Donald Trump has made this year has
been politically tone-deaf he could not
make it look more like he is covering up
something something horrifying if he
hung a sign around his neck reading
cover-up he reeks of coverup and in his
neurosis unsatisfied with having fooled
some of the people some of the time he
is not merely ignored the option a real
president would take invite a full
investigation
he has also waited weeks before trying
the option a skilled traitor would take
shut up and change the subject to say
Meryl Streep and still like a desperate
child he has to keep bringing this
subject up keep shouting those keywords
that he should never speak again
Russia hacking Assange Putin until he
can presumably convince himself that he
has convinced everyone everywhere that
none of it is true and until he can
convince himself everyone now agrees
with him about how strong and powerful
he is and how he has now won it is
madness and it will destroy him December
29th I think we ought to get on with our
lives I think that computers have
complicated lives very greatly the whole
age of computer has made it where nobody
knows exactly what's going on but saying
nobody knows exactly what's going on
means even he doesn't know exactly
what's going on and he can't let anybody
believe that December 31st I know a lot
about hacking and hacking is a very hard
thing to prove
so it could be somebody else and I also
know things that other people don't know
and so they cannot be sure of this
situation pool reporter what do you know
that other people don't know
Trump you'll find out Tuesday or
Wednesday all we found out Tuesday or
Wednesday was his willingness to
publicly advertise his own paranoia
Tuesday January 3rd 8:14 p.m. the quote
intelligence briefing on so-called quote
Russian hacking was delayed until Friday
perhaps more time needed to build a case
very strange the delay was for a family
emergency the delay was of an
intelligence briefing the likes of which
he has reportedly been skipping for two
months Wednesday January 4th 7:22 a.m.
Julian Assange said a fourteen-year-old
could have hacked Podesta why was DNC so
careless also said Russians did not give
him the info Trump has here sited and
given credibility to Assange of
WikiLeaks about whose activities Trump
said in December 2010 I think it's
disgraceful I think there should be like
death penalty or something Wednesday
January 4th 8:27 a.m. somebody hacked
the DNC but why did they not have
hacking defense like the RNC has and why
have they not responded to the terrible
things they did and said like giving the
questions to the debate to H a total
double standard media as usual gave them
a pass Trump has now justified
international espionage against
Americans provided they are guilty of
something or provided he merely thinks
they are guilty of something especially
if the espionage involves Julius Assange
Thursday January 5th 8:25 a.m. the
dishonest media likes saying that I am
in agreement with Julian Assange wrong I
simply state what he states is for the
people to make up their own minds as to
the truth the media lies to make it look
like I am against intelligence when in
fact I am a big fan he cannot leave it
alone he must not only erase what he
himself has just done he must find a new
scapegoat Thursday January 5th 724 p.m.
how did NBC get an exclusive look into
the top-secret report
Obama was presented who gave them this
report in wine politics he asks about
NBC but he does so in his standard way
of scapegoating the media politically
scornfully not seriously not officially
not ominously but the next morning
somebody else does all that for him the
tweet from WikiLeaks the Obama admin CIA
is illegally funneling top-secret
comments information to NBC for
political reasons before P Otis even
gets to read it that tweet was from 548
a.m. January 6 the next tweet is from at
11:51 a.m. January 6th Trump I'm asking
the chairs of the House and Senate
committees to investigate top secret
intelligence shared with NBC prior to me
seeing it he's now desperate enough to
try to change the subject from his
connection to WikiLeaks that he does not
even seem to realize he has just
connected himself to WikiLeaks
perhaps somebody pointed that out to him
too because next by phone through the
New York Times China relatively recently
hacked 20 million government names how
come nobody even talks about that this
is a political witch-hunt
then comes the actual briefing on the
hacking a briefing he had avoided on
hacking he had dismissed from an
intelligence community he had undermined
and accurate comes a very very cleverly
phrased written statement quote I had a
constructive meeting and conversation
with the leaders of the intelligence
community this afternoon I had
tremendous respect for the work and
service done by the men and women of
this community to our great nation while
Russia China other countries outside
groups and people are consistently
trying to break through the cyber
infrastructure of our governmental
institutions businesses and
organizations including the Democratic
National Committee there was absolutely
no effect on the outcome of the election
including the fact that there was no
tampering whatsoever with voting
machines etc did you see what he did
there merely through juxtaposition the
first paragraph describes a meeting with
the intelligence community and it's work
the second paragraph describes the
conclusion that cyber attacks had no
effect on the outcome of the election
composed that way
it's
seems as if the intelligence community
has concluded the hacking had no effect
but the conclusion is only Trump's the
intelligence community's report does it
merely offer a different conclusion it
makes Trump's written statement even
more deceptive and more malicious we did
not make an assessment of the impact
that Russian activities had on the
outcome of the 2016 election the US
intelligence community is current with
monitoring and assessing the intentions
capabilities and actions of foreign
actors it does not analyze u.s.
political processes or US public opinion
when that real version of what the
report did not conclude was officially
released Trump looked like a liar so
that night back to blaming the victim
Friday January 6 10:53 p.m. gross
negligence by the Democratic National
Committee allowed hacking to take place
the Republican National Committee had
strong defense but the intelligence
briefing actually concluded the
Republicans were also act by Russia
Russia just did not distribute its RNC
data so now changed the story again
Saturday January 7 656 a.m. intelligence
stated very strongly there was
absolutely no evidence that hacking
affected the election results voting
machines not touched
he has just erased the subtle deception
and misdirection in his Friday statement
and replaced it with a flat-out
transparent childish lie because he
cannot leave it alone Saturday January 7
703 a.m. only reason the hacking of the
poorly defended DNC is discussed is that
the loss by the Dems was so big that
they are totally embarrassed and here
Trump's story spirals out of anything
resembling his own control of it it has
gone from Russian espionage to him
invoking the hacking of voting machines
to him disparaging half the country
thirteen days before his inauguration to
Saturday January 7th 1002 am having a
good relationship with Russia is a good
thing not a bad thing only stupid people
or fools would think that it is bad we
have enough problems around the world
without yet another one when I am
president Russia will respect us far
more than they do
now and both countries will perhaps work
together to solve some of the many great
and pressing problems and issues of the
world in three hours and 28 minutes
trump has gone from espionage to hacking
voting machines to calling tens of
millions of Americans fools and stupid
to a call for cooperation with Russia
that reads but Lee as if it were written
in response to instructions from a
blackmailer saying you better fix this
Trump you better make us look good Trump
and so the desperation escalates still
further Sunday January 8th 156 p.m.
before I or anyone saw the classified
and or highly confidential hacking
intelligence report it was leaked out to
NBC News so serious the hacking itself
we ought to move on with our lives it's
only being discussed because he beat the
Democrats the possible leak about the
hacking so serious and then meryl streep
changes the topic for him on Sunday
night at the Golden Globes and the final
one of his campaign managers changes it
right back because he cannot leave it
alone
the fact is Kellyanne Conway said Monday
dismissing the need for a Russian hack
investigation and suggesting Trump may
roll back both President Obama's
punishments of them and other US
sanctions against Russia the Democrats
became super duper interested in this
entire issue after the election did not
go the way they quote wanted and the way
they expected Trump himself directly or
via his mouthpieces cannot leave it
alone neither can he alter his personal
connection to WikiLeaks again that
Saturday morning tweet intelligence
stated very strongly there was
absolutely no evidence that hacking
affected the election results but even
without the Russian element the hacking
is WikiLeaks and as a review of his
speeches by thinkprogress.org
showed in the last 30 days of the
campaign Trump invoked WikiLeaks at
least once every day for a total of at
least 164 times in one month October 10
2016 at wilkes-barre Pennsylvania
WikiLeaks
I love WikiLeaks and I said write a
couple of them down let's see during the
speech crooked Hillary Clinton oh she's
crooked folks
she's crooked as a $3 bill okay here's
one just came
out Trump is here interrupted by a chant
of lock her up lock her up his right he
brought up WikiLeaks in a debate he
claimed the WikiLeaks product meant
Hillary Clinton shouldn't be quote
allowed to run for president he
complained in speeches and on Twitter
and it still sits there on his Twitter
feed that there was not enough coverage
of WikiLeaks October 12 946 am very
little pick up by the dishonest media of
incredible information provided by
WikiLeaks so dishonest rigged system but
now Trump says the hacking that produced
the WikiLeaks revelations had no effect
on the election and of course there is
no way an American leader could ever
compromise himself and suddenly be at
Russia's beck and call September 6 2013
9 oh 2 a.m. I wonder how much our quote
leaders have promised or given Russia in
order for them to behave and not make
the u.s. look even worse how do we
resist this monster just keep quoting
him just keep mentioning Russia just
keep remembering he cannot leave it
alone WikiLeaks is the hacking the
hacking is Russia and Trump is WikiLeaks
resists peace